invité de cette seconde partie du 7 su
Yv Denis yvelinois fondateur d'amitié et
solidarité nouvelle association à
desesstination des des familles en
difficulté Isabelle Ramin conseillère
municipal délégué à la jeunesse de
Montini et Eric Steiner directeur du
pôle jeunesse de la ville pour une
opération SOS rentrée qui vise à aider
les étudiants lycéens sans établissement
voilà ce sont les trois prochains
invités qui viendront sur ce plateau
pour le 78 aujourd'hui de ce 10
septembre et puisqu'on parlait
d'éducation avec SOS rentrée éducation
toujours avec la rentrée des étudis
étranger à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin l'UVSQ s'ouvre de plus en
plus vers l'étranger pour étendre sa
popularité comme nous l'explique Alice
Gastine et
Guillaumes Argentine Ukraine Lituanie
Allemagne Royaume-Uni c'est la rentré
pour ces étudiants à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin certains
resteront un semestre d'autres une année
les étudiants qu'on viennent
d'accueillir ce sont des étudiants qui
viennent dans le cadre de programme
d'échange c'estàdire des des échanges
avec des universités qui sont partenaire
de l'UVSQ les autres étudiants étrangers
viennent s'inscrire dans des diplômes
soit 95 nouveau venus sur 2400 étudiants
étranger choix des cours cartes
d'étudiant assurance maladie
l'installation peut vite se transformer
en un parcours du combattant à commencé
par la recherche d'un logement ça
difficile je suis en train de trouver un
col une chambre je sais pas mais c'est
difficile pour moi les difficultés
parfois c'est la langue parce que
parfois leur niveau de français est
insuffisant pour PIR suivre les cours
qui sont donnés en français pour la
majorité des cas après la difficulté
majeure c'est le logement faut pas se
cacher qu'il y a quand même quelques
difficultés pour les étudiants à trouver
un logement de la même façon que pour
les étudiants français d'ailleurs mais
bon on a un service logement qui est
très actif qui est qui a été ouvert il y
a pas très très longtemps donc qui les
aide un maximum comme vous l'avez vu on
a distribué une liste pour les étudiants
qui serent en difficulté encore
aujourd'hui pour trouver un logement
l'université de Versailles SaintQuentin
compte 18000 étudiants et près de 1400
enseignants chercheurs elle a passé 230
accords de partenariats avec des
universités à travers le monde
plridisciplinaire la
NRE pas toujours facile de trouver une
formation lorsque l'on est étudiant
certains n'ont toujours pas d'école
aujourd'hui on va en parler avec vous
isamel Ramin bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes donc élu à la jeunesse
sur la ville de montinil Bretonneux
j'avais annoncé tout à l'heure la
présence des er qui s'occupe du pôle
jeunesse de montinil Bretonneux qui ne
pourra pas être avec nous on l'excuse
mais vous allez le remplacer au pied
levés comme ça il y aura pas de souci
pour nous donner tous les détails de ce
dossier bonsoir également à Denis vous
avez fondé aguille en cours amitié et
solidarité une association à destination
des plus démunis qui a vu le jour fin
août vous allez nous expliquer ce que
vous proposez et puis surtout nous
entendrons votre témoignage sur cette
précarité qui progresse chaque jour pour
l'instant on va parler donc des SOS
rentré et c'est difficulté pour les
étudiants à trouver véritablement une
formation c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui 10 septembre des étudiants
des lycéens viennent vous voir sur le
pôle jeunesse à montinil Bretonneux oui
je rappelle que le pôle jeunesse donc
est situé trois par vie des sources à
montinil Bretonneux qui a pour vocation
une mission d'information d'orientation
de prévention également et d'aide aux
projet pour les jeunes donc
effectivement nous nous inscrivons dans
une démarche SOS rentrée qui donc
accueille des jeunes qui à ce jour au
moment de la entrée n'aurait pas ou une
place au collège une place au lycée ou
une entreprise pour les guider dans une
formation en alternance comment ça
s'explique que ces jeunes n'ai pas de
formation c'est c'est li à quoi ils ne
savent pas encore vers quoi se tourner
c'est des difficultés même de
comportement à l'école qui fait qu'on
leura pas trouvé de place ça peut-être
aller jusqu'au décrochage scolaire et il
se trouve que le pôle jeunesse dans ses
missions grâce à un partenariat avec un
réseau également d'information c'est la
mission locale le Pôle Emploi le CIO la
site des métiers j'en oublierai
certainement Eric senur là aur été
précieux sur ce genre de partenaire
puisqu'il est le directeur du pôle
jeunesse donc des jeunes oui qui se
tourne vers nous et vers le réseau il
pousse la porte de la proximité et c'est
également une grande joie que de se dire
qu'un
établissement municipal peut servir pour
des causes telles que des jeunes qui au
jour de la rentrée n'ont pas encore un
une place au collège au lycée c'est
municipale structure municipale de mon
br et gratite anonyme qui reçoit des
jeunes d'elà de Montin Bretonneux
uniquement design Montin non on demande
pas la carte d'identité un jeune qui
pousse la porte on se rend compte que il
y a beaucoup d'inimontains mais il y a
également des jeunes de la ville
nouvelle entre 15 et 25 ans donc qui
peuvent venir vous voir alors
concrètement comment vous les aidez ces
jeunes un jeune vient vous voir vous dit
je veux faire une formation à la limite
je sais même pas vers quelle formation
m'orienter vous allez l'aider oui oui
alors il y a donc des
informateurs en matière de d'orientation
et également de prévention mais là on
est sur le champ de de l'information
donc le le jeune pousse la Porte du Pô
jeunesse il est reçu première chose on
essaie de de l'écouter déjà puis de le
guider alors toujours dans dans le
respect de la personne mais avec une
méthodologie des des aides mais toujours
vers l'autonomie on ne prendra pas le
téléphone pour lui on le guidera on
l'accompagnera il y a donc des supports
de documentation un partenariat avec le
réseau on va lui donner toute les infos
nécessaires pour l'aider mais en le
laissant autonome de sa démarche je
crois que c'est vraiment la volonté
politique qui s'inscrit au travers le
pôle jeunesse et il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont venus vous voir dans le
cadre du dispositif alors ce jour il y
en a déjà une dizaine je dirais des
garçons pour beaucoup peut-être que les
filles anticipent d'avantage donc des
garçons on a même des cas extrêmes de
décrochage scolairire voà quel profil
justement j'allais vous demander quelles
sont les les situations c'est souvent on
n' pas trouvé l'entreprise qui va nous
aider dans le cadre d'une
alternance on n' pas la place au lycée
dans la filière que l'on voulait donc là
on va essayer de de l'aider au maximum
pour trouver pour trouver solution à son
problème et ça a fonctionné vous avez
trouvé des solutions pour C on n pas à
l'heure du bilan puisque cette action au
22 septembre au 22 septembre et
véritablement vous nous dites que donc
ça fonctionne ça marche tout au long de
l'année vous travaillez aussi avec ces
ces jeunes pas uniquement sur cette
période la CSOs rentré mais il y a des
jeunes qui vont certainement pas trouvé
de formation après le 2 absolument alors
on travaille également avec un service
très précieux de de la ville de Montini
qui est Montini inf faux emploi qui
également en partenariat avec tout le
réseau va aider le jeune he nous on va
s'adresser à des jeunes jusqu'à 18 ou 25
ans ensuite ce sont des adultes qui son
orientés vers d'autres services
évidemment je vais juste m'arrêter
quelques instants sur l'encadrement pour
ces jeunes parce que vous nous le disiez
il y a quelques instants ils ont pas
forcément confiance en eux vous les
accompagnez trouvez aussi plus
d'autonomie hein vous prenez pas le
téléphone pour
c'est le plusile de les écouter et on
imagine que le personnel qui s'en occupe
est spécialisé et formé pour çaès
spécialisé en Information Jeunesse parce
que justement c'est l'écouter pour
ensuite savoir le guider et au-delà de
ça le jeunne qui aura poussé la porte du
pot de jeunesse ce sera déjà un
jeune qui aura l'habitude ensuite en cas
de problème de venir pour d'autres
problèmes de prévention d'addiction de
de d'écoute par le jeunesse propose sé
es mission également de la citoyenneté
puisque le Conseil Municipal des Jeunes
a son quartier général donc et un jeune
qui a envie de monter un projet
également on peut l'aider par une
méthodologie à aller vers son projet SOS
rentrer jusqu'au 22 septembre du côté de
Montini le Bretonneux n'hésitez pas donc
à prendre contact c'est ouvert toute la
semaine sauf le lundi c'est feré du
mardi au samedi et il est possible donc
d'y trouver du du personnel qui vous
accompagnera si vous avez du mal à
trouver justement formation une
entreprise pour vous accompagn entre 15
et 25 ans et pas forcément ini Montin
pas forcément de de Montini le
Bretonneux vous allez rester avec nous
encore quelques instants on va parler
d'un autre sujet amitié et solidarité
c'est une association que vous avez
fondée Yv de fin août dans les ivelines
à Guy encour on passe au 78 sociétés à
présent